I bought rose petals I decorated the
whole living room
and I did it and I proposed and I
actually got down to one knee and
proposed and he said yes
Jamal is all of us
Kim's son reacts after she proposes to
Usman
plus I have a sneak peek of my interview
with Kim where
we get real do you know what it's like
to wake up every single morning and look
into your at your social media and see
how ugly I am how desperate I am I'm
gonna cry sorry how delusional I am
throw up emojis I mean that disgraces me
more in my self-worth than anything
Usman has done so far also this episode
we get a glimpse at the young woman
usman's mom wants him to marry first and
I'm not gonna lie it has me a little bit
nervous for Miss Kimberly
he looks smitten already
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia I hope
you're doing well I had a really nice
chat with Kim I love you I just I
totally love you I watch you we covered
a number of topics from why she wants to
marry Usman to being called delusional
and her self-worth do these comments
even though they're hurtful do they
cause you to reflect and say well maybe
there is some like deeper soul-searching
I should do sometimes sometimes they do
sometimes most of the time I just try to
ignore you know but sometimes I'll read
when I'm like damn that one hit home you
know I'll be sprinkling a little bit of
our conversation throughout the recap
but to catch the full interview make
sure you subscribe to entertainment
tonight's YouTube channel so you don't
miss it so I always enjoy my chats with
Kim alright before we get into the
latest on her and Usman shout out my
karma kicking that goddamn pool Angela
and Michael are still arguing because he
won't take down his Instagram
[Music]
you're in the arms
up he don't care about me what are y'all
gonna realize this oh yes Angela we see
it we see the pain I see Michaels too
Angela goes on to say that Michael
pulled a romance scam on her and she
tells him she's filing for divorce but
[Music]
at this point Angela threatening divorce
goes in one ear and out the other okay
let's move on to Kim and Usman I'm not
very happy about you know you're going
to meet this woman
I'm scared it scares me like what if you
meet this girl and you like her so
please says mom Usman follows her wishes
and sets up a meeting to meet with a
young woman she has waiting for him from
his land remember usman's Mom told him
and Kim that she's not giving them her
blessing unless he marries a younger
woman first and has a child but also
remember that regardless of what his mom
says Kim is still set on being the first
wife and she claims she is not going to
compromise I don't want
you and it sounds so bad to have
feelings for somebody else like you have
for me that is that does sound bad that
sounds normal and I'm scared that you're
going to meet somebody that's younger
than me probably prettier than me and
then you know you're gonna have this
connection with her and then it's gonna
be like
okay I'm still here it will take a very
long time for me to go with that woman
and everyone have this connection and
that is if I'm not in a relationship
think about how far we've been coming
think about how the kind of stages we
pass through before we get to this place
how do you think I've just met lady
because she's young or maybe she's
beautiful it's not possible he's saying
that now but it's all talk until he's
put into that situation we're gonna see
we're gonna see if he's gonna stick to
everything he's saying well now that
Usman is set to see the mystery woman
the next day Kim you got this you can do
this Kim is a nervous wreck and her way
of dealing with her anxiety about it is
to propose to Usman
I know I know Kim
the things we do to try to avoid the
pain of rejection do you know how
awkward that was for me and if this one
doesn't fit we have another
I'm shaking a little bit because it's
just this is a lot for this is a lot
give me a hell yeah
especially not even knowing if I have
the blessing yet this is a lot but I
feel like I need to pull out all the
stops and really just show him like I am
the the one you know I chose to propose
tonight because regardless of what his
mom says I want him to know that I love
him so much and to make sure that I'm a
priority and to make sure that he loves
me the most especially now
I kind of just want to like seal the
deal with them before he goes to meet
this other woman Usman loving her the
most is not gonna be something she's
going to be able to control
see this is why in my opinion
I just don't think polygamy is best for
Kim as of right now it seems as if she's
going to be so preoccupied with trying
to fight for her spot to where she can't
even enjoy and live her own life did he
show her more love today did he show me
more love today let me do something
drastic to prove my worth I want to
remember this night and wear his ring
all right back to the proposal Kim sets
up the room all nice and romantic and
once she invites Usman in you can see
he's clearly surprised you know I love
you right and I'm probably gonna cry
I know you love me you know how much I
love you I love you too babe like more
than you probably even know
I know you love me okay
and we've been through a lot in two
years we've been through a lot
are you telling me this animals so I'm
gonna ask you a question
Usman looks nervous so I'm gonna ask you
a question
will you marry me babe
oh my goodness I can I'm regardless of
anything that happens I want you to know
that I'm always going to be here I'm
always I'm not going anywhere and when
you told him no matter what happens I
will be here I'm like Kim I thought we
agreed you were first wife and nothing
else so what do you mean no matter what
happens so you meant even if you all
don't end up together right that's
exactly what I meant and I I'm sticking
to my guns so and I know everybody's
like okay Kim she finally got you know
but I have to stick to my gun so I was
always pushed second and I'm not gonna
have that happen I don't care who it is
and how much I love somebody I deserve
happiness and love too and I deserve it
on my terms as well you know
a part of my heart goes out to Kim for
sure because
I've had a relationship or two in the
past where I was more concerned about
convincing that person to like me or
convincing them to choose me to a point
where I wasn't even asking myself if I
really like them or if I really like
what they're offering and the wild part
about it is those people I was so busy
trying to convince
I'm so glad it didn't work out oh I'm so
glad because Looking Back Now
I don't want them
rejection is a form of protection okay
if marrying you
what to make you happy in this life
I'm ready to marry you telling you
I never expected this
and I'll repeat and say yes yes yes yes
well Usman can officially say he had a
woman propose to him
[Music]
that's it
foreign
[Music]
because I wasn't sure
[Music]
no no
I'm just kidding Usman tells the camera
Kim's proposal is not normal in his
culture but it was beautiful this is one
of the days that I would never forget in
my life oh you made me cry I'm just
telling you I've never had this and this
was made by the woman that I love this
is crazy you know like
who
I love it I love you
what do you think usman's true
intentions are with Kim do you think he
really loves her in a romantic way
seeing his reaction to the proposal has
me confused because if he doesn't
that man is a great actor he is using
his talents in the wrong way
for me tonight this is wonderful this is
something that will never forget in my
life but I still have to get the
blessing from my mom and I still need to
admit the woman that she wants me to
date and see if she will change her mind
so I'm still scared of what Mom is going
to say but we just have to work out and
see what will happen I don't know
and if this didn't work Kimberly just be
your second wife
Usman said I already have this in the
bag not that she might be the second
wife she will be
somebody just be your second wife
the next day it's time for Usman to go
see his first or second we don't know
where she lands yet potential wife
potentially you know I'm trying to hate
that word potential now baby don't you
think that this clutch is nice on my
body I would have said well babe you're
a little wrinkled
why is he messing with her like that is
it's crazy to me that I did this big
Grand gesture last night and you know I
love it and seeing you get ready for
this today is like it's like a slap in
my face hmm
she thought the proposal was going to
make him change his mind about going if
that is the case some might also call
that playing games even though I
proposed to Usman last night and he said
yes he's still going on this little
meeting date or whatever that his mom
set up killing me it's breaking my heart
don't have fun don't have fun at all
okay be safe but don't have fun okay
she's ugly she said I hope she's ugly
fast forward while Usman is on his date
Kim calls her son Jamal and I really
appreciate how gentle yet honest he is
with his mom there's a woman here that
his mother wants Usman to me today to
have children
with like it'll be like an arranged
thing so he's going he's going to go
meet up
I don't like it but this is what I can
what can I say like a bloodline
I mean this is their culture Jamal this
is their culture it's not mine
I just worked out with my dad
right Kim's ex-husband cheated on her
often
y'all I'm telling you self-love and
healing your heart is so important once
you get her to go through a traumatic
experience you have to take some time to
do the work so you can heal and have
better healthier more enjoyable
experiences because if you don't you're
gonna keep on attracting the same things
the same type of people learning the
same lessons over and over it reminds me
of this clip why
do nice people choose the wrong
people to date we accept the love we
think we deserve
their decision I just
want you to settle for something that
truly won't will make you happy when you
could there is potential for you to have
somebody that is only for you you know
it may take time and you may have to
wait it may take some healing work
whatever you have to do but I just you
know
I understand I understand where you're
coming from Also let's be clear this is
no shade towards Soulja Boy but he's
comfortable in this relationship Kim
isn't I don't want to be the second wife
there's no point in that you know so
what's the point because I love them and
we have a plan and I told you this in
San Diego that you know I was come here
we would get engaged after we got the
blessing and then I would start like the
K1 Visa paperwork to get him there
yes
Kim goes on to tell Jamal she proposed
to Usman and his reaction
says it all
so
um
you know I bought all that stuff to like
the engagement stuff you know I bought
banners and streamers I'm gonna send you
that video
I bought rose petals I decorated the
whole living room
and I did it and I proposed and I
actually got down on one knee and
proposed and he said yes
hi after Jamal takes the moment to
digest the information he calls out
usman's hypocrisy he likes to you by
your face you're not you're not too
happy with me
not yet
tell his mom that you were going to ask
him to meet no
no
it wasn't behind her back because I
asked him I asked him I said are you
going to tell your mom about this he's
like she wouldn't understand but he's
wearing the ring that I gave him that's
behind her back Kim
his mom
[Applause]
good point
yes he would do that to you in a
heartbeat
[Music]
facts this is how you determine if
someone is as solid as they claim do
their actions match up with what they
say Usman could have told her he
appreciated the gesture but it's not the
time she proposed out of fear anyway
knowing good and well it wasn't the
right time
it's a good point Jamal's a smart dude
because that was very very smart it made
me think like wow it's deceiving it's
it's just deceiving I would hope that
Usman is the man I think he is I hope
and pray that because if I find out that
usman's lying to me about making me the
first wife there is no more hope in this
relationship well next week Usman meets
with his first or second potential wife
and unlike him hoped that's exactly
she's quite the opposite
I'm here in his country and then the
reality hit me like this just went to go
meet this woman
foreign
but her face sure didn't make him pull
out his phone real quick we get a
glimpse of this new woman have you seen
her the the new potential wife no okay
I can imagine I can imagine I saw she's
the pretty she's a pretty lady
what what can you teach her
yeah so see how how are we gonna do the
second wife so she's just joking I'm
just joking
all right 90 day fans fam I can't wait
to see what happens make sure you stick
with ET because we are covering it all I
will see you next time
[Music]